[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
الايرانيين يطالبون بوقف الاعدامات بحق
الناشطين ودعوات دوليه للافراج عن
سينمائيه
الموارد البشريه السعوديه تعلن بدا توطين
14 نشاطا من الشرطه البريد بنسبه 100%
الهيئه السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي تكشف وابرز التقنيات الحديثه في
المونديال
في الرابعه
العربيه تتجول في اقدم الاسواق الشعبيه في
ولايه نزهه التي يعكس ثقافه سلطنه عمان
المنتخب
البدايات من الاحتجاجات في ايران حيث
اعلنت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه التي
تتخذوا من النرويج مقرا لها اعلنت ارتفاع
عدد قتلى الاحتجاجات على ايدي قوات الامن
الى 469 شخصا منذ انطلاق المظاهرات منتصف
سبتمبر الماضي وقالت المنظمه ان عدد
القتلى يتضمن 63 طفلا واثنتين وثلاثين
امراه في الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها البلاد
منذ وفاه الشاب
39 متظاهرا على الاقل يواجهون حاليا خطر
الاعدام فيما حضرته من امكانيه تنفيذ
اعدامات في البلاد على نطاق واسام
لقد نظم المئات من الايرانيين مظاهره
حاشده في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن متجهين
بها نحو البيت الابيض وهتف المتظاهرون
مطالبين الرئيس الامريكي بالاستقاظ وعدم
الاتفاق مع نظام الملاليا حسب تعبيرهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احدث هدف في وقت لقيت فيه طبيبه النيرانيه
تدعى ايد رستومي لقيت خطفها في ظروف غامضه
في محافظه
الطبيه في ايران المشاركه في اضراب يبدا
غدا الاثنين احتجاجا على مقتل الطبيبه
ونفى مصدر لايران انترناشونال سيناريو
انتحار عيد رستومي التي كانت تعالج جرح
الانتفاضه الشعبيه مشيرا الى ان الادله
المتوفره تؤكد ان النظام الايراني هو من
قام بقتلها بعد اعتقالها وتم دفن جثمان
الطبيب يوم الجمعه في ما كانت بعض
التقارير تشكك في صحه سيناريو الوفاء
المشبوه في مستشفى جمران بالعاصمه طهران
وتداول الناشطون صورا لعائله الطبيبه
الايرانيه ايدي رستم مجتمعين على قبرها
عقيبه مقتلها بظروف غامضه على يد احد
افراد نظام الايراني
[موسيقى]
الى ملف تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث كشفت
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن معلومات مفادها ان
الولايات المتحده حاولت منع اوكرانيا من
اغتيال رئيس الاركان الروسيه فالرج راسموف
اثناء زيارته الجنود الروس بالخطوط
الاماميه للحرب وكاله الصحيفه ان الولايات
المتحده عجبت معلومات بشان هذه الزياره عن
الاوكرانيين خوفا من ان يؤدي مقتل رئيس
الاركان الروسي الى مواجهه شامله واضافت
صحيفه ان الولايات المتحده طلبت من
اوكرانيا الغاء مخطط اغتيال جراسي موف دون
جدو حيث سن الجيش الاوروبي الهجوم بالفعل
وقتل عشرات الجنود الروس ولم يكن الجنرال
الروسي احدهم والفتاه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الى ان مسؤولا روسيا كبيرا اكد لمدير
المخابرات الامريكيه وليامز اشاره الماضي
بان روسيا لن تستسلم بغض النظر عن عدد
القتلى او الجرح من جنودها وانا الجيش
الروسي قوي بما يكفي للوق حتى في وجه
الامريكي
هذه المعلومات تزامنت مع زياره تفقديه
مماثله اداها وزير الدفاع الروسي الى
الخطوط الاماميه للجيش واعلن عن اليوم
افادت دفاع الروسيه بان الوزير سيرجيو
تفقد القوات الروسيه على الخطوط الاماميه
في اوكرانيا ونشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لقطات ظهر فيها شويكو على متنه مروحيه فوق
مناطق انتشار القوات وهو يتحقق من المواقع
المتقدمه للوحدات الروسيه والتحسينات وكذا
من الخطوط الدفاعيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
في رياض
اطلقت هيئه فنون الطهي النسخه الثانيه من
مهرجان فيست للطعام السعودي
للبيانات والذكاء الاصطناعيه عن ابرز
استخدامات البيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي في
مباريات كاس العالم الكره المتصله والكره
مزوده بتقنيه تدعم القرارات التحكيميه عبر
تزويد الطاقه التحكيمي ببيانات الكره في
الوقت المباشر لدعم قرارات
وهو نظام يساعد على تقديمه تنبيهات اليه
او تنبيهات اليه عن التسلل عن طريق تحليل
بيانات الكره واللاعبين من الاستخدامات
ايضا منظومه بيانات كره القدم وهي مجموعه
بيانات من مصادر مختلفه تضم اربعه عناصر
رئيسيه منها عمليات جمع بيانات الحدث مثل
التمريرات والتسديدات وعمليات جميع
البيانات الموضوعيه حيث يتم جمع احداثيات
اللاعبين والحكام والكره
انضم الينا من رياض المتحدث الرسمي للهيئه
السعوديه لبيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي
المهندس ماجد الشهري مهندس ماجد حياك الله
معي في نشره الرابعه يعني التقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي اصبحت يعني تدخل في كل شؤون
الحياه تقريبا بالنسبه اليوم نتكلم كذلك
عن استخدامها في مجال كره القدم في اكثر
من ناحيه يعني
السؤال الى اي ماده تساعد اليوم مثل هذه
التقنيات خاصه في مجال رياضي مثل مجال
الكره القدم يمكن كان معتمده على الاخطاء
في كثير من الاحيان الحبوب ايضا وكان همم
لها نكهه يعني مختلفه
حياك الله اخوي خالد والمشاهدين في قناه
العربيه فعلا اا في كاس العالم 20 22 في
قطر تم استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي وجمع
البيانات
بعده امور وراينا كيف ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
ساعد في دعم القرارات التحكيميه وتغيير
النتائج ساعد في تحليل البيانات الرياضيه
سواء خلال وقت المباراه او بعد المباراه
وايضا اسراء تجربه الملاعب بالعموم
بالتاكيد ان الهدف من هذا الاستخدام هو
اسراء التجربه تحسين اللعبه ايضا تحسين
همم
الادوار بحيث ان يستطيع الحكم ان يعود الى
مرجع همم ويستطيع ايضا المحل ان يعود الى
مرجع ويتخذ قرارات ويبني رؤى بناء على
بيانات وهذا دور اذا كان الاصطناعي في
معظم القطاعات حيث ان الذكر الاصطناعي
الان يستخدم للدعم وليس همم الو الى اتخاذ
قرارات مباشره بناءا او همم لاستبدال
الكائن البشري
باستخدام مش الاليه اللي يتم استخدام هذه
البيانات في الكره يعني حتى نتصور الامر
يعني لو نبدا بحالات الاستخدام اللي تفضلت
تكسرها قبل قليل الكره المتصله على سبيل
المثال الكونكت بول هذه الكره صممت بشكل
حديث يعني هي كره همم يعني استخدامها
واختبارها لاعبي كره القدم انفسهم بحيث
انهم لا يجدون اي اختلاف بينها وبين
الكرات القديمه الغير متصله همم
صممتها معامل اديداس شركه اديداس العالميه
بالتنسيق مع شركات همم متخصصه هذه التقنيه
تدعم القراءات تحكيميه بتزويد الطاقه من
التحكيمي ببيانات الكره بشكل مباشر يعني
الكره ترسل البيانات بشكل مباشر همم تم
اصدار نسختين لهذه الكره حتى الان همم
نسخه لمباريات النصف النهائي وايضا همم
والنهائي اللي بيكون اليوم ان شاء الله
ونتمنى همم التوفيق
للمنتخبات المش وايضا مباريات ما قبل نصف
النهائي السابقه كان لها تصميم مختلف الان
الكره تحتوي على عنصري رئيسيين الاول هو
السي ار تي كور اللي هو قلب الكره اا فيه
فيه نظام تعليق او سبنشن سيستم جديد همم
بحيث انه يكون في مستشارات الحركه او
السنسرس ايضا صرحت شركه اديداس انه هذه
التقنيه غير ملحوظه يعني بحيث انه
اللاعبين لن يحسوا بالفرق هناك ايضا الجزء
الاخر اللي هو السبيتشال همم يتكون همم من
خلاله هيكل خارجي للكره في 20 قطعه جلد
وايضا يساعد على تحسين دقه واستقرار همم
وانحراف الكره حين التسديد بحيث انه لا
يتغير الاستخدام للاعبين همم ايضا هذه
البيانات تساعد في همم مساعده الحكام في
بعد جمع البيانات في اتخاذ القرارات على
سبيل المثال التسلل شبه الاني يعني الان
نعرف ان هناك بعض ال- همم
ابداع التي سجلت والغيت احيانا العكس
كان يلعب دور في الموضوع انه نتصور انه
الكوره هي تكون السبب في الغاء هدف يمكن
امر ما يخطر على بالك
الفي اي ار هو تقنيه الكاميرا الان احنا
هنتكلم عن الكره نفسها تمد الفي اي ار
سيستمتمد ايضا الحكام الموجودين هناك
بالبيانات الدقيقه من الكره نفسها بحيث
انه تستطيع ان تحلل موقع الكره همم تستطيع
ان توفر بالكاميرات المختلفه التي تتابع
الكره تقريبا اكثر من 12 كاميرا في نظام
التسلل شبه الالي تتابع الكره ويكون في
تقريبا 29 نقطه بيانات لكل لاعب بحيث انه
يحسب الموقع الدقيق للاعب همم
يعني احنا نتاكد الان بالتاكيد انه
الحسابات الدقيقه الان بالتاكيد انها افضل
بكثير مما كان عليه في السنوات السابقه
والان طبعا هذه تجارب جديده بتتعرض اكيد
للاختبارات والتقييم وسيعني ستعلن الشركات
المشغله النتائج بعد كاس العالم واكيد
يعني كان هناك فرص التحسين ستظهر ان شاء
الله في نسق قادمه ايضا هناك المنظومه
الخاصه بيانات كره القدم اللي هي الفوتبول
هذه تجمع البيانات الخاصه بالحدث عن
اللاعبين عن ما جرى خلال فتره المباراه
تجمع كل البيانات هذه همم هناك نظام تتبع
بصري يتابع اللاعبين همم يلتقط وضعه في
خلال الثانيه باكثر من صوره بحيث ان تكون
التصوير الدقيق ثم بعد ذلك تعرض في منصه
بيانات كره القدم هذه تابعها المدربين
ويتابعها الحكام والمحللين بحيث انه
تحليلاتكم تكون مبنيه على ارقام دقيقه
شكرا جزيلا لك المهندس ماجد الشهري
الرسمي للهيئه السعوديه للبيانات والدكان
الاصطناعي
عقدت الهيئه الدائمه المستقله لحقوق
الانسان في منظمه التعاون الاسلامي في
مدينه جده اجتماعاتها في دورتها العشرين
شهدت الجلسه الافتتاحيه مناقشات حول قضايا
منها الحقوق المدنيه والسياسيه
والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والثقافيه وستعقد الهيئه ايضا
الاجتماعات العاديه للفرق عملها 4 المعنيه
بفلسطين وحقوق المراه والطفل والاسلام
فوبيا والاقليات المسلم والحق في التاريخ
في السعوديه كذلك كشفت وزاره الحج والعمره
عن زياده اعداد رحلات العمره والزياره
للمعتمرين من اندونيسيا بعد مناقشه بين
الجانب السعودي والاندونيسي تضمنت اليات
التسهيلات التي اعلنت عنها السعوديه
لتمكين المعتمرين الاندونيسيين من القدوم
والخدمات المقدمه لهم ليؤدوا مناسكهم
بسهوله ويسر واليتر كذلك تجربتهم الدنيا
والثقافيه
السعوديه النسخه الثانيه من مهرجان فيست
للطعام السعودي الذي يستمر لمده اسبوعين
محتوي على مسميات وخصائص المطبخ السعودي
من مقتدى في المناطق في البلاد ويهدوا في
المهرجان لتنميه استكشاف المقطع والمحلي
ونقل الخبرات والمعرفه في الطعام السعودي
ويعد هذا المهرجان واحده من اهم مهرجانات
الطعام في المملكه
من الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي حياك الله عبد المحسن ما هو
جديد مهرجان فيستثني
نعم خالد بالفعل تقيم هيئه فنون الطهي هذا
المهرجان لاهداف عديده منها اعاده تسويق
الاكل السعودي الشعبي بشكل عام واقامه
المسابقات والتنافس ما بين الطهاره وحتى
المناطق والاضاعكم في الصوره لا نتجول
خالد مباشره في هذا القسم طبعا المهرجان
كبير جدا ويحتوي على عدد كبير جدا من
الاقسام منها قسم المطاعم وقسم اخر
للمسابقات ولل همم لمسرح وكذلك اقسام اخرى
تم استحداتها الان هنا في منطقه خاصه
لتراث فن الطهي بال- المملكه حيث همم هو
قسم للتذوق فقط من خلاله يتم تسويق الاكل
السعودي همم عبر همم اقسام المختلفه
ونتحدث عن الاقسام اي- المناطق المختلفه
هنالك منطقه الجو ومنطقه الحدود الشماليه
وتبوك نجران وانجازات وكل منها قدمت همم
سواء كان اسره او عائله او حتى سيده لي
تستعرض اكل منطقتها خاص عبر هذه الاقسام
ونشاهد بالرغم من خالد وكاس العالم نهائي
كاس العالم بعد ساعه لانه هنالك حركه
كبيره جدا
جميع مستمتع في هذا المكان لانه ايضا هذا
المكان يقام في منطقه مفتوحه وعلى الهواء
الطلق في بعض همم عوائل بدات فعليه باعداد
بالاكل الخاص بها
لاستعراضه لكن المعرض او المهرجان فتح
ابوابه قبل ما يقارب 19 دقيقه فبالتالي هم
في طور الاعداد حتى هذه اللحظه هنالك ايضا
مسابقات اخرى تقام على هام الشهاده
طبعا هنا ركن جازان ل اييه نستعرض ابرز
الاكلات لكن زي ما قلت لك خالد ال ال
المهرجان بدا قبل ما يقارب 19 دقيقه
وهم في طور الاعدادي في اكل جاهز الان ولا
لسه
عسل
مع زيت سمسم
من الجزائر المشاركه بالمهرجان
الاقبال ايضا تفاعل الناس مع الاكل الاكل
الجيزاني
انهم يتعرفون عن جيزان وعن الطبخ الجيزاني
الخاص
طبعا طبعا الساعه سبعه على بال ما يخلصوا
الاكل ويكون ويكون جاهز ونكون معهم طبعا
هذه الاقسام خالد هي اقسام للتذوق فقط ااا
وكلها الى هؤلاء العوائل قدموا من مناطقم
لاستعراض الاكلات الخاصه بهم كما تحدث قبل
قليل هناك مسابقات يوميا اتحدث عن افضل
طبق في المنطقه الوسطى في المنطقه
الجنوبيه في المنطقه همم الشرقيه وكذلك في
الشماليه هذه الاطباق هنالك جوائز ضخمه
همم يتم تقديمها 30,000 ريال يتم تقديمها
يوميا لافضل طبعا ايضا هنالك مسابقه اخرى
همم
طبق المستحدث السعودي بجائزه 30,000 وايضا
عمل بالطعام السعودي
وتتمحور حول الطعام السعودي وطريقه تقديمه
وايضا همم تسويقه واعاده همم تسويقه
وتقديمه بطرق حديثه خالص شكرا
عبد المحسن الحربي من الرياض
في حلقه جديده من برنامج خذ العلم تناول
خبير الاستثمار والاداره الماليه صلاح
خاشقجي موضوعات منها مستوى الادخار في
السعوديه وقضايا الاقتراض والاستثمار
اضافه الى التملك بيت العمر وسبل تحقيق
الاستقلال المالي ويمكن متابعه بقيه الزاء
هذه المقابله من خلال برنامج خذ العلم عبر
حساب العربيه السعوديه في منصه تويتر
اجزاء كبيره من رواتب الموظفين
رهينه للبنوك والقروض الشخصيه برايك ما
الاحوال التي تبرر فيها الاقتراض ومتى
يصبح الاقتراض ضروريه
الحاله الوحيده اللي ممكن الشخص يقترض
فيها هي لشراء اصل القرض الاستهلاكي
ممنوع
جمله وتفصيلا ما في ما في اي مجال يعني ما
في نقاش في الموضوع هذا
فكره انك انت تمول استهلاك لحظه بصير
اليوم اااه
رواتب مستقبليه مرفوضه
لابد انك انت تعيش على قد
الدخل اللي بيجيك لكن في حال انك انت
بتشتري اصلا والاصل هذا ايا كان شكله عقار
سياره
اصل استثماري هنا
القرض ما في اشكال بالعكس ممكن يكون ممكن
نشجع عليه في بعض الحالات مو دائما في بعض
الحالات برضو
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
هيئه السياحه تدرج اربعه مدن في دليل شتاء
السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه دخل قرار
وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه القاضي بتوطين انشطه البريد
ونقل الطرود حيز التنفيذ يشمل القرار في
مرحلته الاولى توطين 14 نشاطا من انشطه
البريد بنسبه 100% مع استثناء مهن عامل
نظافه وعامل شحن وتفريغ ويستهدف القرار
توطين خدمات البريد ونقل الطرود وما
تتضمنه من وظائف ايضا لتقديم خدمات
التوصيل عبر المنصات الالكترونيه اضافه
الى انشطه البريد السريع وتقديم الخدمات
اللوجستيه البريديه وانشطه شركات نقل
البريد الخاصه وانشطه البريد الممتاز
وانشطه البريد الاخرى واستعمل الوزاره على
تقديم مجموعه من المحفزات لمسانده القطاع
الخاص في توظيف السعوديين منها برامج
الدعم والتوظيف من خلال صندوق تنميه
الموارد البشريه هدف
استديوهات هنا من الرياض ينضم الينا
الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الموارد البشريه
محمد لطفي استاذ محمد حياك الله معي في
نشاط الرابع اهلا وسهلا فيك خليني ابدا
معك برايك
وباهم النقاط اللي وردت في القرار
والانشطه التي تم توطينها في مجال البريد
والبريد هو ضمن انقطاعات التي تستهدفهم
الموارد البشريه في الايام القادمه
والسنوات والشهور القادمه لتوطين القطاعات
المهمه وخصوصا انه البريد يعتبر ضمن اهم
قطاعات اللوجستيه في البلد
يستهدف يعني قطاع مهم جدا همم يلامس
احتياجات المواطنين احتياجات رجال الاعمال
والمستثمرين وبالتالي من الضروره بمكانه
يكون هناك توطين بشكل عالي جدا وكان الى
اواخر الثمانينات يعتبر البريد السعودي
كان في توطين بالنسبه عاليه جدا لكن في
فتره ما همم تحول من من قطاع همم خدم
استثماري الى قطاع حكومي بحث انه اعاده
همم تاه للبريد واعاده تطويره واعاده
هيكله وباضافه الى توطين اليوم هذا يعيد
لنا ما كان في اواخر الثمانينات الذي كان
همم انا ذاك يعمل في سعوديين بنسبه 100%
كم عدد الوظائف المتوقع كم متوسط الرواتب
اللي ممكن يحصل عليها الموظفين في هذا
القطاع في ال 14 نشاط يعني 100% وفي غير
هذه النشاطات المتعلقه تقريبا معروف
القطاعات اللوجستيه على مستوى العالم انه
ال- ال- الوظائف فيها عاليه جدا وهي همم
قادر على ان تشكل ايضا ليست فقط وظائف
خاصه بريد انما همم على ارتدادها وظائف
اخرى همم بما في ذلك الشحن التوصيل الى
جانب انشاء همم شركات همم ناشئه دائما
لقطاع اللوجستيه دائما البريد لان البريد
اعتمد ايضا على قطاعات ناشئه صغيره متوسطه
وصغيره وبالتالي همم مساله توظيف هتكون
عاليه الجانب الرقم يعتقد انه لدى الوزاره
رقم كبير جدا لكن جلس يتكلم عنه انه ستولد
كثير من الوظائف ليس فقط في البريد حتى في
الشركات التي العمل الى جانب البريد
كمساند لشركات المسانده بما في ذلك الشحن
التفريغ التوريد همم كما انه انه ستشكل
اهميه كبيره بالنسبه لدخل للفرد لما تكلم
عن الموظف الشحن اليوم او موظف البريد على
مستوى العالم في شركات العالميه لا يقل
مرتبه عن همم 2000 دولار الى 2500 دولار
هذا بحدات يعني مؤشر جيد يصل الى مبالغ
عاليه جدا يعني بعد موظفي همم شركات همم
القطاع اللوجسته صلواتهم الى اكثر من
50,000 دولار هذا ما يؤكد انه هذا القطاع
من اهم القطاعات العالميه في ايصال او في
دعم وتعزيز القطاع التجاري القطاع الامني
اللوجستي همم كل قطاعات المهمه الاقتصاديه
في البلد وفي العالم حول العالم الى اي
مدى يمكن ان ينجح هذا القرار في قطاع
البريد تحديث
على مستوى جوده الخدمه المقدمه للناس الان
تعرف انه في كثير مثلا
الى الان في في بعض المجالات برامج
التوطين واستراتيجيه التوطين كانت عشوائيه
الى حد ما هو وثبت فشلها ربما مثلا على
مستوى التطبيقات التوصيل لبعض يتحدث عن
ذلك على مستوى اوبر مثلا على مستوى جوده
الخدمه تاخير في بعض البعض يتحدث عن هذا
الامر فبالتالي الى اي مدى يمكن الاستفاده
من التوطين في معالجته هذه المشاكل اللي
حصلت في في مجالات اخرى استاذ خالد هي في
اليه المشكله ليست في التوطين بقدر لانه
كان هناك مشكله في اليه هيكلت بعض
المؤسسات والشركات انا ذاكر لم تضمن حقوق
كثير من الموظفين احيانا همم لم توجد ضمان
وظيفه لبعض الموظفين بمجرد ان يشعر الموظف
السعودي والموظفه مثل اي موظف همم اجنبي
بمجرد ان يشعر على حقوقه مكتمله بمرتب همم
تامين طبي 100% ستكون الوظيفه بالنسبه
لمصدر امان ولذلك اليوم لما تشوف مثلا
الشركات التابعه للدوله والقطاعات التابعه
للدوله حينما توطن موظفينها تجد هناك حرص
من الشباب والف على التقديم عليها
والمحافظه عليها ففي السابق لم يكن فشل
بقدر ما انه كان هناك شركات همم تدار من
قبل عماله اجنبيه وكان هناك نوع من التستر
التجاري فكان الموظف السعودي ضحيه تستر
تجاري اللي جالس يصير اليوم الحمد لله انه
الدوله جالسه تصلح الهيكل التشريعيه
للشركات والمؤسسات تعيد النظر في موضوع
التستر ايضا تتاكد من ضمان وتوثيق العقود
الان ويمكن لو شفت انت في الطرق السعوديه
اليوم اعلانات بشكل كبير موارده بشريه
لتوفيق العقود والاضمان حقوق الموظفين
وبالتالي ضمان حق الموظف ايا كان همم يؤكد
نجاح التوطين 500% شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب
الصحفي المختص في الموارد البشريه محمد
فارس
تستمر الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه بتقديم
كافه المعلومات للسياح القادمين الى
المملكه ضمن خطط الترويج لفعاليه شتاء
السعوديه
يستهدف هذا الدليل اربع مدنها الرياض جده
العلا والاحسن العربيه رصدت جزء من هذه
الفعاليات في العاصمه الرياض ضمن دليل
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
وليال يطول فيها السهر هذا ما يحدث في
شتاء السعوديه الرياض اكبر مدن السعوديه
والمنطقه واهم الوجهات السياحيه المدرجه
على دليل شتاء السعوديه
[موسيقى]
يعني بيكون اجواء حلوه كثير
ونخرج انا والعيله
بنستمتع بالاجواء وخصوصا بعد موسم بالرياض
سهره كثير حلوه
[موسيقى]
بوليفارد رياض سيتي اولى الوجهات التي
قادنا اليها دليل شتاء السعوديه لهذا
العام هنا يمكن لاطفالك اللعب بينما
تستمتع بشرب القهوه او تناول الطعام على
انغام الموسيقى
والله الموضوع اخذ اقل من خمس دقايق يعني
هو عبينا طلب اون لاين
رجع ايميل كونفرميشن خمس دقائق وبالموا
فقط
الامارات او دول الخليج عامه والحمد لله
يعني بنشكره ذلك يعني
وجينا كمان على البلوفيد هون كثير اجواء
حلوه مختلفه انا جيت زمان عن الرياض فكتير
مختلفه الاجواء زمان
[موسيقى]
العاصمه تذوق القهوه السعوديه
والتعرف على انواعها وتاريخها وطرق
تحضيرها في كل منطقه سعوديه هنا متحف قصر
المصمك ابرز المعالم التراثيه السعوديه
هذا المكان يمنح الزوار رحله فريده ممزوجه
بين التذوق والمعرفه
[موسيقى]
حتى المقاهي تتغير في الرياض خلال فصل
الشتاء فبين الابراج الشاهقه جلسات دافئه
على الرمال وقهوه سعوديه تاخذ الزوار الى
عالم اخر من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
لكاس العالم من الداخل تحديدا من محيط
ملعب لوسيل ملعب المباراه
الجديده
والكل الان يترقب موعد انطلاق صافره
البدايه منها هذه الجميله يعني كيف هي
الاجواء وكيف تنطبعت الناس
ههه يعني خالد لوسين تحول الى سيل من
البشر كما تشاهد في عمق الصوره ولكن هنا
مشجعون من لبنان ارجنتينيه ومن السودان
فرنسي يعني الارجنتين اليوم لبنانيه
وفرنسا سودانيه طيب كيف بتشجعي فريق
الارجنتين رايحه على المباراه ولا لا
احنا اكيد بنقول انه مرسي حياخذها هذه
السنه لانه هو نعتبره هو ابن مراد وانا
وبستحقه
انه هو افضل لاعب
بمباراه هولند ومع كرواتيا انه الارجنتين
فاكيد اليوم حتكون فاموس
ولكن الهدف واحد هالمره احمر الشفاء ازرق
وابيض والعيونر
بشوف هيك طريقه تشجيع كل واحد الى طريقته
شكرا لك سمعينا ايش شيء من الهدافات اللي
بتدفوها
قبل ما حضرتك تنتقل عند الشخص اللي حدك
انا بدي اوجه تحيه لقطر بدي اقول لهم
الامير الوالد انه حلم هيدا الحلم ابنه
حققه بطريقه مذهله نحنا براد اوف قطر
لذلك يوجد الحشود الذين يتواجهون الى
الملعب الاستاذ خلف الكاميرا وكذلك الذين
يحتفلون في عمق الصوره انت هلا السودان
يا اخ يا سوداني عن فرنسا عن منتخبك همم
في الاول يعني بنحيي دوله قطر على هذا
التنظيم الرائع التنظيم الخرافي الذي ابهر
العالم اجمع يعني وكله اجمع على احسن نسخه
نظمت في العام 20 22
وصراحه
اليوم اليوم انا ان شاء الله مشجع للمنتخب
الفرنسي وانا كنت مشجع له في مونديال 2018
بروسيا همم
فايت على الملعب بعد شويه ان شاء الله
راح تقول قال لي البلو مثلا فيفا لا فرس
تحيا فرنسا ان شاء الله نتمنى عن الكاس
اللي مبابي
والكثير من الجمهور برضه
بيحب اهدي اللقب ايضا لميسي لكن طيب عندي
سؤال خالد اذا سمحت
خليني اسالك سؤال
الارجنتيني والفرنسي بقطر عم يتبادل
الهتافيت مع ابتسامه وهيدا تشيلي مميز قطر
الروح الرياضيه المميزه هيئه السنين لانه
ابل كانيست سيتي كثير مشاكل فانا هيدا من
فجاه قطر حاولت انه تفرجي حب بين المشجعين
الفرنسي والارجنتيني انا بقول فاموس
ارجنتينو ميسي اكيد هياخدها ومارادونا
الله يرحمه بس اكيد هو هلا عم بعرف
انا ادافع عن المنتخب الفرنسي المنتخب
الفرنسي غير غريبه عليه البطولات ودي دي
دي مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي مو اول مره ياخذ
لقب والتيم جاهز حتى الاحتياط ممكن جاهزين
اكثر من المنتخب الاول على كل حال
[تصفيق]
كاس العالم راح نشوف الرابع
[موسيقى]
المباراه النهائيه بين ارجنتين ميسي
وفرنسا مبابي كل التوفيق للمنتخبين
تهانينا للقطريين والقطر ايضا بالعيد
الوطني وبهذا التنظيم ايضا رائع
لكاس العالم 2022 شكرا جزيلا لك ليت بازار
من الدوحه
[موسيقى]
يعتبر سوق نزوى من اقدم الاسواق في سلطنه
عمان يمتد عمره الى مئات السنين ويتميز
بالخرف اليدويه والفضيات والفضائع التي
تعكس ثقافه السلطنه مثل الملابس التقليديه
الخناجر والتحف التراثيه الاضافه ايضا الى
سوق الجمعه الشهير يقصده التجار من مختلف
الولايات لبيع المواشي عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
الاسواق الشعبيه في ولايه نزوى لها نكت
خاصه تسوق الجمعه الذي نحن فيه الان فما
ساعات الفجر الاولى يتوافد التجار من خلال
هذا الباب لبيع الاغنام والاسماك والابقار
الى جانب الخضروات والفواكه وغيرها من
البضائع
[موسيقى]
الحركه التجاريه الناشطه في هذا السوق تعد
مثالا للاسواق الشعبيه التقليديه وانعكاس
لتاريخ الولايه العريق بحضارتها المتمثله
بقلاعها وحصونها وبيوتها الاثريه وحاراتها
القديمه
[موسيقى]
السوق نزوى يقصده كثير من
الباعه والمتسوقين من خارج ولايه نزوه ومن
خارج المحافظه على مستوى السلطنه سوق نزوى
يتميز
بتعدد الاغراض المتوفره فيه
بكافه انواعها
وهو سوق تراثي سوق حراثي سوق اقتصادي بكل
ما تعني الكلمه من معنا
[موسيقى]
الاطفال لهم حضور في سوق نزوى رفقه ابائهم
كي يتعلموا التجاره مبكرا
[موسيقى]
فسبنا مثلا تجاره من الاباء من قبل واحنا
كنا صغار في المعذره الوالد في السوق
واكتسبنا يعني مثل هذه التجاره والحين ما
شاء الله الحمد لله مستمرين عليها واكيد
راح نورث التجاره يعني علمهم على هيئه
التجاره والاستمرار فيها في سوق نزوى من
النادر ان تشاهد اجنبيه يمارس التجاره
الغالبيه هنا من الشباب العمانيين
كما تلاحظ ان سوق نزوه وسوق من تاريخ
وثقافه الولايه في المنطقه ومن سارف العصر
كان سوق نزوى عقب
بالزباينه ونزلوا مقصد سياحي ومقصد تجاره
في نفس الوقت
[موسيقى]
في هذا السوق فعاليات متنوعه لجذب الزوار
يستطيع الزائر ان يؤجر بالساعه سياره
كلاسيكيه ليتجول بها في انحاء نزوى
القديمه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه نزوى
العربيه
[موسيقى]
يعد الظل من اهم الطرق المستخدمه في معرفه
دخول وخروج المواسم عند العرب القدماء مع
خالد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من الطرق المستخدمه عند العرب قديما
وحديثا في معرفه دخول وخروج الفصول
والمواسم
الظل وهي من ادق الطرق الحسابيه عندهم
وهلنا لوليد الله يرحمهم يقولون اطول
حالات الظل الزوالي في السنه دليل على
دخول مربعانيه الشتاء واقصر حالات الظل
الزوال في السنه دليل على دخول مربعانيه
القيض واذا توسط طول الظل الزوالي اعتدل
الزمان ومن دقه الظل جعله المولى علامه
على دخول مواقيت الصلاه اقيم الصلاه لدلوك
الشمس الى غسق الليل وقران الفجر ان قران
الفجر كان مشهودا فصلاتيه الظهر والعصر
على الظل المباشر وصلاتي العشاء والفجر
على الظل الغير مباشره المغرب مع مغيب
الشمس والظل
ثم من ايات الله الم تر الى ربك كيف مد
الظلم ولو شاء لجعله ساكنا ثم جعلنا الشمس
عليه دليلا اطول حالات الظل اليوميه في
حال شروق وغروب الشمس واقصر حالات الظل
اليوميه في حال الزوال مرات والديبي معك
مثل ظلي ومرات ودي انك اقرب من الظل تبيه
صراحه يا بعد كل ملي وانت معي ما همني
غيبك
الكل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مئات المثقفين الايرانيين يطالبون بوقف
الاعدامات بحق الناشطين ودعوات دوليه
للافراج عن سينمائيه بارزه
الموارد البشريه السعوديه تعلن بدات
توطينها 14 نشاطا من انشطه البيت بنسبه
100%
اللي هي السعوديه للبيانات والذكاء
الاصطناعي تكشف ابرز التقنيات الحديثه في
المونديال
والعربيه تتجول في اقدم الاسواق الشعبيه
في ولايه نزوى الذي يعكس يعكس ثقافه سلطنه
عمان
مسيره الارجنتين بالمجد وفرنسا بقياده
مبابي تامل الاحتفاظ باللقب
شكرا
[موسيقى]